Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Der Papst ist tot.
Ja, sehr, sehr traurig, denn für mich war es wirklich eine der wichtigen pazifistischen Stimmen, die ja sehr selten geworden sind. Und er hat ja noch in der Ostermesse dazu aufgerufen, dass endlich Frieden einkehren soll in Gaza. Für mich ist das wirklich ein großer Verlust. Das sage ich als Nicht-Katholik, aber ich habe gerade diese politischen Interventionen des Papstes immer sehr gemocht und es war ja auch ein Papst, der quasi quer zu Julia Klöckner stand, die ja jetzt gerade noch mal die Kirchen dazu aufgerufen hat, bitte nicht so politisch zu sein, sondern sich doch auf die Kernthemen zu konzentrieren, so als sei die Kirche eigentlich was ganz Unpolitisches. Und das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Und das wusste natürlich Papst Franziskus immer. Ich habe nicht alles gemocht, was Franziskus gesagt und getan hat. Und auch seine Kapitalismuskritik fand ich ein wenig halb gar, wenn ich das sagen darf. Aber ich fand ihn als einer der wichtigen Stimmen im globalen politischen Rahmen doch eigentlich unersetzbar. Denn man kann ja nur hoffen, dass jetzt wieder jemand kommt, der da eine ähnliche weltkirchliche Sicht auf die Dinge hat und nicht plötzlich wieder zum Beispiel so eine sehr europäische Verengung stattfindet.
Interessant, dass du da so viel zu sagen kannst zum Papst. Ich denke hier nur an Konklave und so, was jetzt für einen Krieg vor Ort zugeht. Denn so eine Papstwahl scheint ja sehr kompliziert zu sein. Papsttod an einem Ostermontag ist aus zwei Gründen super interessant. Denn dein kleiner Nachruf ist wahrscheinlich mehr Text als gerade in diesen Redaktionen entsteht, weil es ist ja niemand da. Alle sind ja in den Osterferien und währenddessen kommt die dpa mit so einer roten Meldung, was wirklich nur alle fünf Jahre passiert. Also Papsttod, Queen Tod, Papsttod. Das ist glaube ich in den letzten drei roten Meldungen gewesen. War ja in der FAZ-Redaktion, als der letzte Papst starb. Das ist schon dramatisch. Kleiner editorischer Einschub. Benedikt ist ja damals gar nicht gestorben. Das war erst 22. 2013 ist er vom Amt zurückgetreten. Und so wenig Leute wussten, ob sie gerade richtig hingehört haben in so einer Andachte, der das ankündigte. Das hat natürlich die Redaktion besonders in Aufruhr gebracht. 11 Uhr und alle sind am Arbeiten und wissen, oh krass, jetzt muss hier so richtig und wir brauchen jetzt bis 17 Uhr acht Seiten Politik zum Papst. Also hier ist es mit einem Nachruf nicht getan. Vor allem, wenn seit der letzten Messe, die du erwähnt hast, und dem Tod dann noch JD Vans zu Besuch war. Das sind ja alles Sachen, die müssen jetzt noch kurz aufgeschrieben werden. Ja, da muss jetzt der Italien-Korrespondent noch mal kurz von der Küste aus zurück in sein Urlaubsdomizil, um ein paar Texte zu schreiben.
Naja, ja der arme Mann, dass er das auch noch erleben musste, auf JD Vans zu treffen, das hätte man ja ihm wenigstens ersparen können. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie jetzt die mediale Berichterstattung ist. Ich hoffe, dass man auch wirklich dieses politische Mal mehr hervorhebt, dass man jetzt nicht einfach nur sagt, naja, er war auch einer, der sich immer um die Ärmsten kümmerte oder so, das geht ja dann doch an vielem vorbei. Und es war doch sehr erstaunlich zu sehen, wie der Papst ja auch immer in dieses Gefängnis ging, um dort diese Fußwaschungen zu machen. Und es ist interessant, dass er jetzt auf dem Weg dorthin noch einmal interviewt wurde. Also er ist da in diesem Auto und die Reporter stehen da und fragen ihn jetzt also Karfreitage. Er fährt dahin und sagt dann jedes Mal, wenn er diese Schwelle übertritt zu dem Gefängnis, fragt er sich, warum die, warum nicht ich? Also da zeigt sich natürlich auch so eine besondere Größe dieses Papstes darin, dass man genau das eigentlich anerkennt, was wir immer einfordern eigentlich von diesen Silicon Valley Größen, nämlich dass man erkennt, dass man nur ein Mensch ist, dass man eigentlich auch auf der anderen Seite stehen könnte, dass man es nicht verdient hat, dass man eben nur einer unter vielen ist. Und das zeigt sich da besonders, dass sich also der Papst fragt, warum bin ich eigentlich nicht in dem Gefängnis, warum die, wären wir sonst nur solche Größenwahnsinnige, Elon Musks und Putins und Trumps haben, die sich für geradezu unsterblich halten. Und da ist natürlich so eine Figur wie der Papst so ein wunderbarer Kontrapunkt in unserer Öffentlichkeit, dass man ja hoffen kann, dass wieder eine solche wahre Größe dann auf den Thron steigen wird.
Ich verbinde ja so einen Papst auch immer mit so, der ist grundsätzlich alt und irgendwann tot. Bin gespannt, ob die Kirche sich traut, mal sich auf eine Jahrhundertfigur einzulasten. Dadurch, dass diese Amtszeit bis zum Tot dauert, ob man mal U60-Papstsiege kriegt oder so.
Ja, naja, das ist ein großes Risiko, dass man natürlich dann auch eingeht.
Radikalisierung im Amt sind in alle Richtungen möglich, haben wir gesehen.
Jaja, in der Tat. Wir wollen aber noch darüber sprechen, was wir demnächst lesen, nämlich im Neuen Salon, der dann Anfang Mai erscheinen wird. Und diesmal soll es um zwei Bücher gehen. Das eine stellst du uns kurz vor, es ist bislang nur auf Englisch erhältlich, wird aber, nein, ich muss mich selbst unterbrechen und noch auf eines hinweisen. Im vergangenen Sommersalon haben wir ausführlich über den Papst gesprochen. Nämlich wir hatten damals diesen Brief vorgestellt des Papstes über den Wert der Literatur in der Bildung. Also wer das noch mal nachhören will, kann das natürlich jetzt auch tun im Sommersalon August 24 war das. Jetzt aber zu dem, was wir als nächstes lesen. Das ist ein Buch, das im Oktober auch auf Deutsch erscheint. Jetzt aber schon heiß diskutiert wird. Alle mischen sich ein von David Brooks über Adam Toos, nämlich das Buch Abundance.
Ich habe es noch nicht gelesen, aber es ist ja schon eine Weile da. Also wir haben sozusagen schon zwei Salons ohne Abundance gemacht. Abundance ist als Titel ein Titel, der auch vor zehn Jahren schon mal eine Runde machte, nämlich Überfluss. Damals ging es um die digitalen Sachen, also hier Sinnüberschüsse, Informationsüberschüsse, was auch immer. Andrew Kean hieß er, glaube ich, hat darüber geschrieben. Und diesmal geht es ja, und wir haben ja schon bei Alex Karp gehört, jemand soll ja mal wieder was bauen. Nicht Beiz, sondern was war sein, Atoms, Atoms, also Atome. Jetzt muss wieder hart gebaut werden. So und jetzt gibt es widerstreitende Lesarten, bevor man das Buch gelesen hat, worum es in diesem Buch geht. Ja, denn wir wissen, es wurde geschrieben als Wahlkämpfer stattfanden.
Ja, und Adam Toos ist der Auffassung, dass es schmerzhaft gewesen sein muss, dieses Buch zu Ende zu schreiben. Denn Adam Toos sagt Abandons, also von Esra Klein und Derek Thompson, ist eigentlich ein Buch, das dann zur Programmatik werden sollte für die Amtszeit von Kamala Harris, die ja wie wir alle wissen nicht eingetreten ist. Du hast aber, glaube ich, eine andere Perspektive darauf.
Ja, denn für solche Projekte wie Abandons, und ich habe ein paar Podcasts schon gehört, er war bei Kehrs Fischer zu Gast, er war sogar in diesem All-In-Podcast zu Gast, der eigentlich mehr die Trump-Präsidentschaft jetzt, sag mal mal, intellektuell unterfüttern soll, soweit das geht. Das Programm in Abandons oder das Anliegen ist ja, ein politisches Programm der Demokraten zu gestalten, das eine echte Wende bringt, nämlich in dem man, Beispiele sind dann vor allem Housing, Wohnung bauen, aber auch so was wie große Zugverbindungen, dass man mal im chinesischen Stile einen Feiertag hat, wo einfach mal alle in den Zug steigen und dann 100 Millionen Amerikaner zeitgleich Hochgeschwindigkeitszüge fahren oder laute solche Sachen. So, jetzt ist natürlich, Kamala Harris hat nicht gewonnen, sondern Donald Trump und Donald Trump zeigt der Welt, wie weit man Politik treiben kann, wenn man will und die Inhalte sind austauschbar. Denn Donald Trump ist ein Abbauer. Der reißt gerade alles ein, der bereichert sich, der macht irgendwie Börsenbewegungen von 10 Prozent am Tag und so. Da werden einfach zehn Billionen geschöpft, vernichtet und wieder geschöpft und so. Also man sieht, es ist ganz schön viel möglich. Und wir haben jetzt einen deutschen Koalitionsvertrag, in dem irgendwie 88 mal drinsteht. Wir werden prüfen, ob und so weiter und so fort. Statt einfach auf drei Seiten zu schreiben, nee, also Frankfurt, Köln muss jetzt in drei Stunden mit dem Zug erreichbar sein. Ansonsten sind wir als Regierung gescheitert.
Gut, Frankfurt, Köln ist ein schlechtes Beispiel. Da klappt es tatsächlich.
Frankfurt, Berlin mein ich. Frankfurt, Berlin, genau. Frankfurt, Köln ist das Beispiel und Frankfurt, Berlin ist gefordert. Oder 400.000 Wohnungen. Also das kann man sich eine Regierungszeit leisten, oder es ist auch egal, wer regiert. Das kann sich eine Bundesregierung einmal leisten, das Ziel, um die Hälfte zu verfehlen. Das heißt, nur die nächste Regierung muss es auf jeden Fall machen. Und diese ganzen Ambitionen stecken im Koalitionsvertrag nicht drin, sondern das sind alles, wie die Journalisten in Berlin sagen, Prüfaufträge. So, Abandons will jetzt etwas. Und es könnte durchaus sein, dass man die Schwungmasse der Trump-Regierung, dass sie vielleicht förderlich ist. Also dass es sozusagen nicht darum geht, jetzt Kamala Harris und sie hat gerade so gewonnen und eigentlich muss man jetzt noch mit dem Zorn der Trump-Wähler, die nicht zum Zuge kamen, rum sich boxen, sondern nein, die ganze Welt sieht, was es bedeutet, wenn man einmal politisch richtig zulangt. Das passiert jetzt dreieinhalb Jahre lang noch oder vier Jahre grob grundet und das Programm danach. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass Abandons ein Buch ist, das sehr gut altert.
Möglicherweise. Es ist ja auch eine Kritik an einer gewissen linken Politik, die sich gerade nicht auf das Bauen konzentriert, nicht darauf konzentriert, dass der Fortschritt etwas bringen kann, sondern eher einen Fortschritt skeptisch ist. Wir sehen aber hier bei Abandons, dass es eben nicht nur um Überfluss geht. Interessant, dass du es als erstes so übersetzt hast, sondern Abandons meint ja auch Wohlstand oder vielleicht das beste Wort für dieses Buch scheint mir Fülle zu sein. Und Fülle meint nicht super jachten, sondern meint ein gutes Leben mit einer Bahn, die funktioniert, mit Straßen, auf denen auch Autos fahren können, aber eben auch Stadtteile, in denen keine Autos stattfinden und denen das Leben pulsiert. Über all das schreiben Esra Klein, der ja von der New York Times ist und Derrick Thompson zusammen. Und ich glaube, es ist ein Buch, das sehr amerikanisch ist, nach allem, was ich jetzt gehört habe, also sich sehr oft das Amerikanische konzentrieren, das wir aber sehr gut übersetzen können dann für unsere Debatten. Und damit nicht genug. Wir wollen diesmal zwei Bücher lesen, denn wir haben ja schon ein Konzept vorgestellt bekommen, wie der Start der Zukunft aussehen sollte, nämlich in dem Buch von Alex Karp, das wir vor zwei Monaten besprochen haben. Und wir haben ja schon gesagt, das ist eines der erschreckendsten Bücher, das wir je im Salon gelesen haben. Es scheint ein Gegenbuch dazu zu geben. Und das lässt sich wahrscheinlich ganz gut mit Abundance kombinieren. Das heißt, die Welt nach dem Kapital, Strategien für das Zeitalter knappe Aufmerksamkeit, Disruption und Zukunft des Kapitalismus im Zeitalter künstlicher Intelligenz. Und zwar ist es verfasst worden von Albert Wenger. Er ist Risikokapitalgeber und schlägt einen anderen Weg vor. Es soll also nicht darum gehen, jetzt einfach nur zu sagen, wir brauchen ja wieder nur Militär und dann ist alles gut, sondern ist es tatsächlich ein Appell für einen Paradigmenwechsel. Und wir müssen dabei auch sehen, wie wir eigentlich mit unserer eigenen Aufmerksamkeit umgehen. Sagt jetzt also einer, der investiert. Also noch mal so einen Investorenblick jetzt drauf zu bekommen und zugleich den journalistischen Blick, der sagt, hier wird nicht investiert oder nicht genug. Das ist, glaube ich, eine ganz gute Kombination. Das Buch ist auch bereits auf Deutsch erhältlich. Albert Wenger, Die Welt nach dem Kapital, bei Piper erschienen. Abundance, wie gesagt, bislang nur auf Englisch. Mittlerweile gibt es das auch als Hörbuch zu hören, wem das vielleicht genügt. Jedenfalls sind jetzt gerade die gebundenen und die Taschenbuchausgaben etwas schwierig in Deutschland zu bekommen. Ich hab's jetzt über Amazon Frankreich mir bestellt.
Ein Lob auf das digitale Buch.
Ja, über Kindle und weiß ich nicht was, kann man es natürlich bestellen.
Na, man kann es wahrscheinlich auch direkt beim Verlag einfach in welcher digitalen Form auch immer bestellen. Das sollte nicht mehr die Hürde sein. Was den Teil angeht, bin ich gegen Atome. Aber gut, Standardthema von mir überhaupt. Ich bin da sehr gespannt. Ich möchte mal sehen, wie, aber wir werden es wahrscheinlich dann auch. Ich bin über ein Wort gestolpert, das mich wirklich sehr ärgert, dass ich jetzt immer höre, der Finanzierungsvorbehalt.
Ja.
Denn wir sind die FDP gerade losgeworden, die ja die ganze Zeit kam mit, wir machen da mal eine kleine Reservierung im politischen Programm für Merkposten, wie Lindner das nannte, für irgendwelche Programme, die er nicht finanzieren wollte. Nun kommt ein SPD-Finanzminister, lasst klingen bei, sehr wahrscheinlich, der uns die ganze Zeit erzählt, alle Stimme unter Finanzierungsvorbehalt. Also wir werden dieses Buch, bevor es auf Deutsch erscheint im Herbst, jetzt schon mal auf deutsche Perspektive trimmen und damit dann auch den Koalitionsvertrag noch mal einschätzen.
Es ist grotesk. Ich hab ja den gesamten Koalitionsvertrag mit Ole gelesen. Also nicht vorgelesen, sondern wir haben ihn gelesen, um dann eine Folge dazu zu machen. Und es ist schon sehr lau, sehr mager, was dort angeboten wird. Und nach vielen, vielen Seiten steht dann plötzlich tatsächlich dieses Wort da. Alle vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen stehen unter Finanzierungsvorbehalt. Und man denkt sich so, ja, das war ja schon eben viel zu wenig. Und jetzt ist das auch noch erstmal mal in Frage gestellt beziehungsweise unter nur gewissen Bedingungen möglich. Es ist absurd. Wir sind hier nicht am Ende der Austeritätspolitik angekommen. Das kann eher noch massiver werden. Ich sehe da wirklich dunklen Zeiten entgegen. Insofern wichtig, dass wir uns wappnen mit anderer Literatur, mit anderen Blickweisen. Und das werden wir dann tun. Wir wollen an dieser Stelle noch einmal ganz eindringlich werben für den Salon. Das ist nämlich die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Im Salon sprechen wir, wie gesagt, immer über ein oder jetzt sogar zwei Bücher ausführlich miteinander. Und dann schlagen wir aber jeder noch wichtige Texte vor, die wir gelesen haben oder Bücher vor, die wir gelesen haben. Es ist also ein Debattenformat am Anfang und am Ende läuft es dann aus zu einigen Empfehlungen bis hin zu einem Musiktipp dann noch von mir. Wer das sich anhören möchte und auf diese Weise den Podcast unterstützen möchte, kann das ganz einfach tun über Steady. Man geht auf neu20er.de, auf den goldenen Button muss man klicken und dann kommt man zum Abo und kann natürlich dann auch gleich alle alten Folgen nachhören. Also zum Beispiel wäre sehr empfehlenswert auch nochmal sich die Folge mit Alex Karp anzuhören, der da doch ein sehr dystopisches Szenario uns als Utopie verkaufen will. Und wer jetzt das nicht über Steady machen will, schon bei Patreon ist, kann selbstverständlich auch darüber uns abonnieren. Und jetzt sagst du uns noch Stefan, du als Apple-Kunde, wie geht es darüber?
Bei Apple, also wenn man unseren Podcast über die Apple Podcasts App hört, die ja von uns Podcastern auch eine als sehr gut eingeschätzte App ist, dann taucht da ohnehin der Salon einfach auf und dann kann man den einfach anklicken mit einem Klick, aber für 50 Cent mehr. Also wir haben schon eine Präferenz für Steady. Man kann auch den Steady RSS Feed in der Apple Podcasts App abonnieren, nur dann sind es wieder drei Klicks. Also wer diesen einen Klick machen möchte, der klickt einfach direkt im Abonnement, also im kostenlosen Abonnement der Podcast-Folgen. Die Neuen Zwanziger dann auch noch auf den Salon und kann dort hören.
Wunderbar, dann sehen wir uns im Salon und am Ende des Monats in der neuen Folge.
Bis denn.
Bis dann.